[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
joey good morning thanks for joining us
what's your walk up song
jolene dolly parton
jolene by dolly park dolly parton
does she know it
[Laughter]
i don't know i don't know didn't she
recently pass on the the rock and roll
hall of fame i kind of respect that i
don't know why but i respect that but
she did get voted into the hall of fame
how does that work so you get voted in
but she didn't she pass on the ceremony
she didn't want to be nominated
oh interesting and they said no sorry
dolly you're going to be nominated
and then they put her in it was jolene
always your walk-up song no i i've used
quite a few i there's something about
that it just feels sexy
[Laughter]
what's the worst walk-up song you ever
heard
i've ever heard um
i don't um
wow i walked out to a a jingle from
saturday night live i was wearing really
tight pants during that time and a lot
of people were giving me a hard time and
there's a there's a skit where uh will
ferrell and someone else um
uh
it's about i got my tight pants on and
so i walked out to that and people were
laughing i did that only a few at bats i
didn't like being distracted by it but
that was one of the worst ones i've ever
heard coming from me obviously but when
you choose your uniform do you want it
to be looser or you want it to be
form-fitting
now now it's about comfort you know i i
dress on the field exactly how i dress
off the field you know i've got
no name brands everything's bland
everything fits comfortably my shoes are
comfortable i want socks that are easy
to put on in the morning
a a sweater
and it's the same thing with my uniform
i want everything so comfortable that i
don't even notice it i used to want to
be cool and now i'm just about
how do i do my job well
what are you sound like you're 68 not 38
i do i feel that way i very much feel
that way style has been is a is a is a
past version of me i i no longer get
into that sort of stuff all right
explain this to me then bottom of the
eighth inning and you know that well you
know that very well yes i do yes yes
that's how i dress how you dress is
exactly how i dress dan
bottom of the eighth
you're up to the plate chicago reliever
rowan wick threw a pitch
pretty close to your head you had
already hit a home run and a triple
so what
what happened
oh okay all right um so
um my interpretation of what happened
so
um and i'm i'm sure he has his own um
i when i'm hitting
i i don't i it doesn't matter if you
throw the ball at me because
hitting comes with being thrown at
so
because the pitch was close the pitch
was close to me
i if i just don't register it like i
view it as ball one and how how do i get
into the box prepare for the next next
swing
prepare for the next quality pitch to
hit
and
he walks me on four pitches uh sometimes
pitchers just can't find a feel um i
never ever during that at-bat felt like
i was being uh uh thrown at or that
there was any sort of aggressiveness i
just thought oh just not as tight during
that bat
i'm gonna go to first and as i ran down
to first i you know there's a there's a
rhythm to hitting and pitching
um
the
the generation i came up
and even you know today but especially
the generation i came up uh 16 years ago
now um you don't talk to one another or
else you run the risk of being thrown at
you run the risk of getting into a dust
up possibly bench is clear you don't
want to make enemies you just want to do
your job
and now this generation is kind of the
same there's a little bit more
showmanship
but as i was running down first
i felt the rhythm of the pitcher batter
exchanged
i felt like it was thrown out because he
said something to me
and
uh often times
uh
picture battered pictures and batters
don't say anything to one another so i
reacted i said something back to him
well he called you an mf right
oh you
i can read lips i can read lips jokes
um
you know it's not it's not a common
experience and so i i reply with an
uncommon
uh
an uncommon and you know i don't usually
say i want it it's done the bat is so
hard that
that just getting to first base is a
success you want to bask in that but
does this have to do with a bad flip
at a previous sid bet
a bat flu yeah did you did you have a a
gesture
you know okay
he's i think he's dominated me to be
honest with you
our entire and he's so big that
if i i you know the exchange i actually
was i started uh kind of talking to him
getting angry and i was like joey calm
down he's going to
bear hug you and sangeef you know uh
pile drive you this guy is going can
slap you around in front of everybody
but he says to reporters after the game
joey
that
nice bat flip
you know uh i've got like
1300 career walks um
it's perfected by now so um
you know my my you know um
my take is
thank you yeah thank you uh yeah but you
know then the back and forth and i felt
like
i felt like uh there was a bit of an
exchange but we move on this is part of
it this is what makes it fun competition
is fun when's the last time you went to
the mound
went to the mount yeah or at least
that direction
never
never gone after a pitcher
oh my god i'm not trying to be
embarrassed here
are you kidding me what am i some kind
of tough guy i hit i'm fine at that i'm
not a fighter
i mean
goodness no no never never been to a
mountain i'm a coward
gonna go out there and be embarrassed if
you were a pitcher you could be a
pitcher you can't be a pitcher on your
own team but you can be any pitcher in
baseball who would you want to be for
one game
um
i i love clayton crochet i'm such a
you know one of the classiest
most competitive he he tows that line of
competitiveness but then he's got a
a real grace to him and um i'd like to
know what it feels to be the best
pitcher of this generation
in in in in in
one of the most iconic uniforms in one
of the biggest cities in the world
um i i'd love to know
i'm perfectly happy being myself but in
this hypothetical alternate universe
where i am some other pitcher clayton
kershaw would be my choice
would
do you care how you look when you strike
out
do i care how i look when i strike out
um
no i i do i yeah it's not it's true yeah
uh i i do care i do care how i look when
i strike out because
when if you strike out
um you can you can roll
if you strike out in such a way that
that can breed future success you can
roll that
you can roll that into upcoming bats you
know or if or if there's a pitch that's
probably outside of the zone that's
called strike three you can pat yourself
on the back and say
you know i i i i need to not swing at
that pitch to be successful in the
future so
the answer is yes i do care
talking to joey votto the reds first
baseman six-time all-star mvp back in
2010 when you got 2 000 hits
something like that at least that yeah
what do you think you need for the hall
of fame
um
you
know i've i've been asked that question
a lot over the last couple years
i need i need
people like you
it doesn't matter how many hits i need
people like you to not ask that question
in that
what do i need to be a hall of famer i
need dan patrick to say future hall of
famer joey botto as opposed to what do
you need
and so um do you think you're a future
hall of famer
uh if if you're asking me how many hits
i need the answer is probably no
if that makes sense
so
uh i don't know and i don't have a vote
and and
i'm really in a place in my career where
i just want to play well but if you're
asking the question how many hits do you
need the answer is maybe no
so
it's an interesting answer
no it's not i i mean i i you listened to
uh
you know a long time uh members of the
media and their response is does he feel
like it okay the answer's no
and if you're asking that question then
i mean we just talk about clayton
kershaw does he do you ask how many
strikeouts he need he needs no he's a
hall of famer
there you go
there you go so you're the answer is
yeah maybe not
you might be the hall of very good
maybe maybe
maybe but i i don't vote and i i
sometimes i try to understand the the
criteria for what is a hall of famer and
how it's changed in generations
yeah well if i don't feel like one
in line with clayton kershaw then maybe
i'm not one
uh how do you keep the perspective of
it's a long season the way you guys
started out
uh
you know you have to do your own job can
you laugh it off
no
no it's we started 3 and 22. there's no
laughing about that
um is there crying
there's some moments there's some
moments where you're driving to work and
you're you're you're slamming the wheel
or you're thinking
why isn't this easier but um
[Laughter]
no it wasn't a good start there's no
laughing now that was funny
so you like you broke the tension there
yeah that was that was funny instead of
crying you laughed you left yeah but do
you have do you take on a different role
as the veteran the leader of this team
of letting the younger players know
hey
we got a long season
in my behavior
uh oh you're not a talker
here and there there's a time for it but
i do think that um
never showing that there's give
like you give in or that um
you're you're you're
you're happy with or you're satisfied
you know showing that every single day
uh you're in the fi you know and it's a
you're in a foul mood or you're
dissatisfied with with how we're playing
is is
it's probably the route that i go um i'm
not satisfied unless we're a successful
team unless we're a playoff championship
caliber team so
i got the uh
let's see
the oldest player before you to hit a
triple and home run in the same game
you know who that is
no happened in 2016.
okay
and uh it was david ortiz
david ortiz
very good very good hall of famer david
ortiz
no doubter you wouldn't have asked him
how many triples do you need to get into
the hall of fame david one more is there
a part of you that says i don't need a
triple let's just stay at second
no
no no you can't probably can't leave the
league in triples if you stay inside
oh you're planning on leading the league
in triples
the league lead starts with one yes
paulie how many triples does joe do you
know how many triples you have in 16
years
i guess probably 20 maybe 15 no maybe 20
20 25. right
okay it went from 16 to 20 to 25. paulie
you taught me that's the range
uh i got 22. he's under 42
22. how many did babe ruth have
yes babe ruth hall of famer
okay who's the hall of famer now
right now right now where you go
hall of famer mike trout clean
kershaw babe had 136 triples just to let
you know well they played in the polar
bear okay brown balls all right okay um
so kershaw trout like if their careers
stop right now albert pujols kershaw
trout trout right now even if if he was
done tomorrow
oh my goodness not even close okay all
right
okay um
best player
we the both of us might ever see um
would you rather be trout
or shohei ohtani
trout it's not even close
now i love i love shohei i love shohei
but um
i i
i don't think i don't think trout
gets um he makes so much money too oh my
god
um
that
uh
but trout
doesn't get even the credit he deserves
um
shohei special but trout trout's
bad years are probably better than
shohei's best years
if i'm honest with you i know the
pitching special but
trout is
i mean
he's a 10-win player and uh he's
averaged that over stretches like nine
and ten wins and i think shohei's
shohei's mvp your year last year was
like seven or eight wins something like
that paulie what do you have to make
joey feel better
dan joey votto has hit 300 for his
career and he's got 333 career home runs
players with who hit 300 for their
career and hit over 330 home runs
there's only 20 all-time ted williams
babe ruth willie mays frank thomas
miguel cabrera manny ramirez on and on
and on all of them in or going well
manny's not going in cabrera is going in
like piazza pizza's already in joe
dimaggio i'm hitting like i'm hitting
like a buck 60 right now that 300's
that's that's 300 i may not maintain
that so
they're gonna have to ban that shift
soon
real soon maybe well mickey mantle
batted what 298 for his career he
dropped down under 300. yeah he had 500
homework yeah he did he did that's all
right
do you feel better or worse after this
interview
um
i feel like um
i feel
i don't feel good because i dress like
you that's the thing that stands out to
me you and i have the exact same
like i wore almost the exact same hoodie
to work today
and
what makes me feel
like what what
that
you have to ask me whether or not i'm a
hall of famer
and i have to answer it
the worst part about it is dan honestly
the worst part about it is
i get this question asked yeah are you a
hall of famer and it's at the point now
where people are uh asking the question
like
sell me sell me you know what
i don't i mean
but
it's a compliment to ask you if you
think you're a hall of famer
what if they didn't ask you
how would you feel about that
um
if they didn't ask me nobody's asking
harold reynolds if he's a hall of famer
or anybody
nobody is asking daryl
nobody
if he's got a vote i just lost a boat by
the way yeah yeah you're cooked that's
okay yeah
but shake it off okay come on get a base
knock come on let's go come on joy here
we go
[Laughter]
[Applause]
does that ever help when somebody says
come on baby come on let's go come on
little bingo come on you can do it
no no no it doesn't help no no no blocks
as good as it hit come on joy let's go
it's not
it's not as good no a hit is a hit a hit
is a hit yeah a walk a walk sucks
a walk is
it's so passive it's so passive hey uh
nice walk
oh no nice
that's what he said
that's what he said hall of famers don't
do that
well maybe i'm not one clearly i'm not
one
you just cemented your career as not a
whole thank you all very good
yeah uh happily happily very good is
better than good it is it is uh
thanks for joining us joey i'm so glad
to join you if you ever need to have
your you know morale picked up spirits
picked up i'm the guy for you
okay by the way do you wear uh x or
large or 2x
uh
extra large extra large
i'm sending you hoodies
okay all right very good i'm going to
send you a uh it's link soul that i wear
i'm sending you a pile of hoodies that
you can wear
and maybe you just just wear the hoodies
and nothing else and you think of me
okay
okay very good i'll um i'll okay sounds
good i can't wait
thank you joey thanks there that's uh a
future hall of famer joey votto joining
us on the program hall of fame interview
golly he's funny uh
i undersold him when i said he's a great
interview